this is the new vivaro from opelvox high
with sales of over 600 000 units the
lavaro's captured 10 percent of the
light commercial vehicle market in
europe
now with the second generation built in
close cooperation with renault and
nissan
opel is after even more of the market
share of this growing segment
the car makers are focusing on keeping
the cost for the customer down
for one they've extended the time
between inspections from once every year
and 20 000 kilometers to every two years
and forty thousand kilometers
that considerably reduces operating
costs
more savings come from the choice of
engine for the new bavaro a 1.6 liter
twin turbo
this powertrain has made a lot of
progress in terms of fuel efficiency
compared with the previous vivaro it
consumes about one and a half liters
less fuel per 100
kilometers fleet vinegar
car tester matas kurat is quite
impressed with the vavaros twin turbo
engine he says it's nippy free revving
and still thrifty
the 1.6 liters put out 88 kilowatts of
power and pushes the van up to a top
speed of 171 kilometers per hour fuel
consumption is rated at a decent 5.9
liters per hundred kilometers our test
model featured start stop technology to
recoup breaking energy and save even
more
opal made sure the new vivaro actually
looks like an opal with the makes own
design language the flowing blade side
feature and the signature wing design
for the daytime running lights the new
bigger edition also offers more space
says behind the rear doors is the new
valvaro's 2.53 meter cargo space
10 centimeters longer than before
or to get practical again three euro
pallets placed end to end
and with that flap opened up the driver
can slide long objects like roof beams
and pipes under the passenger seat all
the way into the footwell
depending on the wheelbase the new
vivaro can transport loads up to three
and three quarter meters long
the interior hints at the downside of a
three-way joint venture with the blowers
rimmed in piano black
the instruments and navigation system
and silver
and
the stick shift in chrome a coherent
design would have served better on the
upside the cabin has plenty of storage
space
would like to point out another feature
designed to make the driver's life
easier he has to pull over first
it's the center front seat that he can
easily fold down
and take the back off
to use as a clipboard
a crisp transmission and responsive
steering also add to the plus side
especially on a van where handling like
this is unexpected
realizes this is no luxury car it's a
tradesman's van and what's important to
tradespeople is the cargo space
in the new addition it's 10 centimeters
longer and quite a bit more practical
the good ideas that went into the cabin
and the longer payload area are definite
pluses the new vivaro can tally up
against its competitors
the vivaro's competitors in germany are
the vw t5 van the ford transit the
mercedes veto and saturn's jumpy in
germany the new bavaro starts at just
over 28 000 euros a competitive price
for a competitive van
but it's the fuel efficiency that just
might tip the scale it will also be
available as a combi van with seating
for nine for a price of just over 30 000
euros
you